Evet canlarım. Şimdi ne diyoruz? Orta
Çağ'da bilim, kültür ve sanat. Hemen
başlayalım. Zaman kaybetmeyelim. Orta
Çağ'da başlıca medeniyet havzaları var.
Bunlar hangileri? İşte Biladüş Şam. Yani
günümüz Suriye toprakları Biladü Şam
olarak geçiyormuş. Irak toprakları,
Hicaz bölgesi, Sicilya, Batı bölgesi
yani Avrupa, Endülüs, Mave, Rayün,
Nehir, Harezm ve Türkistan, Fars,
Irak'ı, Acem, Azerbaycan ve Horasan
Havzası. Bir de Çin toprakları bir de
Hindistan. Şimdi bunlar Orta Çağ'da
başlıca medeniyet havzalarıymış. Biz
bunları böyle ince ince bir görelim.
Biladüşam dediğimiz yer Suriye ve
Emeviler döneminde Suriye başkenti
olduğu için çok gelişmiş bir yerdi. Ve
bu dönemde ve o dönemde günümüze gelen
müthiş bir eser var. O da nedir? Emeviye
Cami çok ünlü bir camidir. Irak'sa
arkadaşlar Abbasiler için çok önemli bir
kentti. Hatta Bağdat Abbasileri
başkentlik yapmış bir şehirdi. Tarihsel
önemi çok büyük. O yüzden Bağdat'ta da
günümüze gelen bir eser var. Hz. Ali
türbesi bölgeden günümüze kadar ulaşan
sayılı mimari eserlerden bir tanesi.
Hicaz toprakları Mekke, Medine ve Taif
kentlerini içine alan bölgedir. Yani
Hicaz bölgesi deyince üç tane kent akla
gelir. Mekke, Medine ve Taif. Yani
kutsal bölgeler. Bu bölgede ne var?
Zaten Kabe var. Hicaz bölgesinin en
önemli mimari eseri Kabe. Bakalım.
Sicilya toprakları yani İtalya
coğrafyası. Sicilya'nın başkenti
Palermo'da yürütülen ticari, bilimsel ve
kültürel faaliyetler Avrupa ve İslam
dünyası arasında önemli bir köprü görevi
gördü ve Sicilya'da Palermo katedrali
dünyaca ünlü mimari eserlerden bir
tanesi. Batıda yani Avrupa'daysa
arkadaşlar Roma İmparatorluğu
parçalandıktan sonra kilisenin etkin
olduğu skolastik düşünce dediğimiz bir
akım ortaya çıktı ve Orta Çağ Avrupa'sı
kasıp kavurdu. Yani papa, kilise, din
adamları ne diyorsa o oluyordu. Bilim,
sanat pek gelişmiyordu Orta Çağ
Avrupa'sında ve inanç akıldan üstün
tutuluyordu. Yani biz buna ne diyoruz?
Skolastik düşünce diyoruz. Avrupa'da
Salisburi katedrali diye bir katedral
var. O dönem İngiliz mimarisinin önemli
eserlerinden bir tanesi. Endülüs
dediğimiz zaman aklımıza İspanya
gelmeli. Avrupa topraklarında İspanya
bölgesi gelmeli. Müslümanların
İspanya'ya geçmesinden sonra Müslümanlar
Avrupa'yı olumlu anlamda çok geliştirdi
ve etkiledi. Orta Çağ Avrupa'sında,
Endülüs bölgelerinde mimari eserler
oldukça güzelleşti. farklı farklı mimari
öğeler ortaya çıktı ve o dönemlerden
günümüze kalma eserler bakıyoruz Elhamra
Sarayı, Kurtuba Medresesi günümüze
ulaşan o dönemin en önemli mimari
eserleri arasında. Mavi Raun Nehir,
Harezm ve Türkistan bölgelerinden iki
tane önemli eser var. Bir Semerkant
Medresesi ki Karahanlılar dönemine ait
bir medrese. Bir de Buhara Medresesi.
Zaten bu Semerkant'la Buhara
Karahanlıların en önemli merkezleri
arasında. Pars, Irak'ı, Acem, Azerbaycan
ve Horasan havzasında kadim, çok eski
dönemlere dayanan bir zenginlik var. Ve
bu bölgelerde özellikle İran
topraklarında Büyük Selçuklu hakimiyeti
olduğu için Selçuklu'dan önemli eserler
kalmış. Ama bunlar arasında en göze
çarpan Melik Camiiymiş. Selçuklulardan
kalma. Hindistan coğrafyasına
baktığımızda felsefede, kimyada ve tıp
bu alanlarda gelişmişlik var.
Matematikte, geometri alanlarında büyük
gelişme göstermişler bu coğrafyada. ve
Hint medeniyetiyle İslam medeniyeti de
ne yapıyor? Kaynaşıyor. Çünkü Hindistan
coğrafyasında Müslüman devletler, Türk
devletleri de görülüyor. Mesela Babürler
bunlardan sadece bir tanesi. Dolayısıyla
Türk İslam kültürünün etkinlik
kazandığı, güçlendiği bir coğrafya
olmuş. Ve o bölgede Kutup Minar Zafer
Anıtı diye bir önemli eser varmış. Yani
çok mu önemli bizim için? Aslında değil
ama müfredatta olduğu için söylüyorum.
Yoksa Babürlerden ya da Hindistan
coğrafyasından kalma dünyaca ünlü en
önemli eser Hacı Mahaldır değil mi?
Biliyorsunuz dünyanın yi harikasından
bir tanesi. Çin deyince gerçekten
medeniyet akla gelebilir. Çin hakikaten
de arkadaşlar tarihsel anlamda dünya
medeniyetine birçok şey kazandırmış.
Mesela kağıt, barut, matba, pusula gibi
icatlar bu bölgeden çıkmış. Tarih,
felsefe, mimari alanlarda Çin kendine
özgü gelişim sergilemiş. Bunlardan bir
mimari eser bakacaksak, büyük vahşi kaz
pagası bölgenin en önemli mimari
eserlerinden bir tanesiymiş. O zaman
şöyle bir toparlarsak, Asya medeniyet
Havzaları dersem Çin ve Hindistan
medeniyet havzaları gelsin. Batı yani
Avrupa'dan bahsedeceksek Orta Çağ'da,
Batı Avrupa'sında katedral ve
manastırlar dışında çok pek bir şey yok.
Yani zaten Orta Çağ Avrupa için karanlık
bir dönemdi. Daha sonrasında İtalya,
Fransa ve İngiltere'deki kültür merkezi
ortaya çıktıkça daha gelişme
gösterdiler. İslam medeniyet havzaları
çok daha gelişmişti Orta Çağ'da. Hicaz,
Suriy, Fars, Irak, Mavi, Raun, Nehir,
Harezm, Türkistan, Endülüs ve Sicilya
bölgeleri İslam medeniyet havzaları
olmuş. Yani İslamiyetin yayıldığı ve
İslami öğelerin dünyayı etkilediği
havzalar. Şimdi önemli Türk İslam
bilginlerine bakalım. Farabi çok önemli.
Dünyada böyle gerçekten sayılı
isimlerden bir tanesidir. Pozitif
bilimlerin öncüsü olarak biliniyor.
İslam felsefesini temellendiren ünlü
Türk filozofudur. Farabi maddi servetle,
parayla, pulla pek işi olan bir adam
değil. zaten ruh ve ahlak temizliğine
önem veren bir isim. Halisü Sade diye
bir eseri var. Burada da felsefi
erdemlerden bahsetmiş. Onurlu, ahlaklı
olmaktan, iradeli olmaktan bahsetmiş.
Mantık bilimine çok şey kazandırmış.
Zaten mantık bilimini en iyi açıklayan
bilim insanlarından bir tanesi
Farabiymiş. Aristo'an sonra zaten ikinci
öğretmen yani Muallim-i Sani olarak
ifade edilmiş. Muallim-i Sani ne demek?
İkinci öğretmen, Aristo'nun mantığını,
felsefesini en iyi anlayan, açıklayan
isimlerden bir tanesi. İslam dünyasında
siyaset felsefesinden bahseden ilk
filozof Farabi olmuş. Eserlerinden
bazılarına bakalım. İhsaül Ulum, Kitabül
Musiki Elkebir, dünyanın ilk müzik
kitaplarından bir tanesidir. Kitabül
Musiki. Bir de ne varmış? Talüsü Sade
Farabi'nin önemli eserleri arasındaymış.
İmam Gazali yine çok önemli bir isim
arkadaşlar. Yani yaklaşık bundan
günümüzden 1000 yıl önce mezhepçiliğe
karşı çıkmış bir isim. O dönemde böyle
mezhepler yoktur, mezhepler yanlıştır
gibisinden söylemler gerçekten zordur.
Cesaret ister. Gazali bu noktada öncülük
etmiş. Gazali'ye göre zaten şüphe
gerçeğe ulaşmanın tek yolu. Gazali'nin
en önemli eseri İhyaül Ulumüddin adlı
eser. İbn Rüş'te bakacaksak batı
dünyasında Averroes olarak biliniyor.
Batılıların Avrupalıların en iyi bildiği
Müslüman bilginlerden bir tanesi İbn
Rüşt. Neden? Çünkü endülüslü bir Arap
bilgin. Yani Endülüs İspanya
topraklarında o bölgelerde yaşadığı için
Avrupalılar İbn Yüş'ten çok
etkilenmişler. Yaptığı gözlemlerle güneş
lekelerini gözlemleyen bir bilgin olmuş.
Yani güneş üzerindeki lekelerden
bahsetmiş. Aristo'nun en iyi
yorumcularından, en büyük
yorumcularından biri olarak kabul
ediyor. Bak Farabi de öyle. İbn Rüş de
böyle. El Külliyat-ı Fit Tıp diye bir
eseri var. Avrupa'yı aydınlatan bir
eser. Avrupalılar bu eserden çok
etkilenmişler. İbni Rüşt Avrupa'nın en
iyi tanıdığı bilim insanlarından bir
tanesidir. Buna dikkat edin. Bir de ne
olarak biliniyormuş batıda? A Res. Bu
çok önemli. Geldim Bir'ye arkadaşlar.
Bir Gazneli devleti döneminde yaşamış.
Yani o Afganistan Hindistan bölgesine
hakim olan Müslüman bir Türk devleti
vardı Gazneliler. O bölgelerde yaşamış
önemli bir matematikçi, astronomi
uzmanı, coğrafyacı, müthiş bir adam.
bilimsel çalışmalarında deney ve gözleme
yer veriyor. Akılcı ve eleştirel bir
yaklaşımı söz konusu. İbn Sina ise
arkadaşlar dünyada tıp alanında bilinen
bir bilgin. Zaten İbn Sina deyince batı
dünyasında Avisenna olarak biliniyor ama
İslam dünyasında eşeyhür reis olarak
ifade edilmiş. İbn Sina'nın en değerli
işi El Kanunu Fit tıp adlı eserdir.
Zaten tıp bilimine öncülük yapmış
isimlerden bir tanesi. Tıp deyince akla
İbn Sina gelmeli. İbn Sina günümüzden
yaklaşık 1000 yıl önce idrar testi filan
yapmış. Yani idrar incelemesiyle şeker
hastalığının teşhisini, tespitini
yapıyor. Bunlar o dönem için gerçekten
dünyada hatrı sayılır işler ve dünyada
gerçekten de o dönem İslam dünyası bilim
anlamında, felsefe anlamında,
matematikte çok ileri düzeydeydi. O
yüzden İslam medeniyet havzaları birçok
medeniyet havzasına göre çok daha
ilerideymiş. İbnül Heysem'e bakalım.
Optik biliminin öncüsü. Optik bilimi den
biliyor musunuz? ışığın özelliklerini
inceleyen bir bilimdir ve modern optiğin
temellerini İbnül Heysem atmış. Yani
ışığın doğrusal yayılımı, yansıması,
kırılması, gölge oluşması, gökkuşağı
gibi konularda deneyler yapmış. Bu da
çok ilginç bir zeka o dönem için. En
önemli eseri, bilinen en önemli eseri
Kitabel Menazir ya da Kitabül Menazir
adlı eser. Doğu batı arasında bir
medeniyet köprüsü inşa etmesi açısından
İbn Sina Farabi ve Biruni bir dönüm
noktası olmuş. Özellikle İbn Sina'nın
tıp alanında, Farabi'nin felsefe
alanındaki çalışmaları batı dünyasında
olumlu etkiliyor. Çünkü doğuda yaşanan
bu gelişmeler batıya aktarılınca batı
bundan faydalanıyor. Mesela İbn Sina'nın
El Kankanunu Fit tıbb adlı eseri batıda
Latinceye tercüme edildikten sonra
Avrupa'da ne oluyor? Ameliyatlarda bile
kullanılıyor bu eser. O zaman şöyle bir
yorum çıkarabiliriz. ortak dünya
mirasının oluşumunda İslam dünyası ve
Batı medeniyetinin ortaklaşa hareketi
söz konusu. İslam dünyası daha
ilerideydi. Batı medeniyeti bunu aldı.
Rönesanstan sonra özellikle gelişime
kaydettiler. Modern bilimin ortaya
çıkmasında özellikle Batı dünyasının
yani Avrupa'nın da katkıları oldu.
Yanlarım anlatacaklarım bu kadar. Umarım
sınavlarınızdan, yazılarınızdan yüz
alırsınız. Görüşmek üzere. Kendinize iyi
bakın.